attention c'est parti attention on
pouveit taper dans vos mains si vous
voulez ça se fait
[Musique]
beaucoup les enfants du docteur bobo le
matin se lèvent tôt pour cacher les
médicaments les pistouries les ciseaux
les enfants du docteur bobo de jour en
jour exagère ils aiment bien taquiner
leur per pu mettre un peu des terre dans
sa pipe ou dans sa tabatière les enfants
du docteur bobo s'amusent toujours
beaucoup au téléphone il faut les voir
inventé des rendez-vous en imitant la
voix de leur pè il rie comme des fous
allô allô venez am il non pas à midi je
dois auosculter mon canari oh là là là
quelle
famille raison Madame bobo
elle rêvait d'une vie tranquille et
c'est le carnaval de r les enfants du
docteur bobo se moquent des visiteurs
ils font peur à tous ceux qui ont une
maladie de cœur que l'on soigne pour le
foid sont encore plus énervés car les
enfants viennent de leur tirer souvent
les poils du nez les chatouilles et sous
la plante des pieds les enfants du
docteur bobo pendant les consultation
vont dire bonjour à leur papa et c'est
la révolution ils jettent du poil à
gratter et commence la bagarre et c'est
vraiment difficile à croire on les a vu
hier soir de battra coup de suppositoire
oh là là là quelle famille elle a raison
Madame
bobo qui rêve d'une petite fille mais au
monde des jumeaux qui deviendront comme
tous leurs frères la terreur des clients
de leur pèr
elle a raison Madame bobo c'est le
carnaval à r attendez monsieur romain
attendez pour le final attendez pour le
final alors où ils sont nos petits
camarades de tout à l'heure vous voulez
venir vite en vitesse non ils ont ils
ont peur ils sont timides on va le
chanter avec Michel SARD allez viens
viens viens vite allez attention 1 2 les
[Rires]
[Musique]
enfants ch